Samira López: Today’s focus: incident postmortem action items.
Avery Kim: Any blockers from last time?
Avery Kim: Let’s aim for a concrete owner and rollout plan.
Samira López: Observability dashboards for errors on incident postmortem action items.
Riley Chen: We need to timebox the spike on incident postmortem action items.
Riley Chen: Action: write migration.
Avery Kim: From QA perspective, Performance baseline needs to be recorded.
Jordan Patel: Let’s not block on incident postmortem action items; start with a spike.
Priya Singh: Risk: scope creep for incident postmortem action items.
Avery Kim: Risk: data migration for incident postmortem action items.
Riley Chen: Let’s not block on incident postmortem action items; ship a thin slice.
Avery Kim: My take is we split incident postmortem action items into two subtasks.
Riley Chen: Infra-wise, We need to align with capacity.
Riley Chen: Let’s keep this within this sprint on incident postmortem action items.
Samira López: I think we split incident postmortem action items into two subtasks.
Riley Chen: Action: book design review.
Noah Williams: Edge cases around auth and retries on incident postmortem action items.
Priya Singh: Risk: scope creep for incident postmortem action items.
Avery Kim: Risk: accessibility gaps for incident postmortem action items.
Priya Singh: I propose we split incident postmortem action items into two subtasks.
Jordan Patel: From QA perspective, Security review is likely.
Noah Williams: We’ll need QA test cases listed on incident postmortem action items.
Riley Chen: Any risks we’re missing? on incident postmortem action items.
Riley Chen: Let’s not block on incident postmortem action items; ship a thin slice.
Riley Chen: From design side, Quick update on the scope.
Riley Chen: I propose we split incident postmortem action items into two subtasks.
Jordan Patel: Let’s not block on incident postmortem action items; ship a thin slice.
Riley Chen: My take is we split incident postmortem action items into two subtasks.
Jordan Patel: Risk: accessibility gaps for incident postmortem action items.
Priya Singh: Let’s not block on incident postmortem action items; parallelize testing.
Jordan Patel: Let’s not block on incident postmortem action items; ship a thin slice.
Samira López: Action: write migration.
Noah Williams: I think we split incident postmortem action items into two subtasks.
Avery Kim: Let’s not block on incident postmortem action items; parallelize testing.
Samira López: From design side, We will stage it behind a feature flag.
Noah Williams: Coordinate with SRE for rollout on incident postmortem action items.
Priya Singh: Risk: scope creep for incident postmortem action items.
Samira López: I propose we split incident postmortem action items into two subtasks.
Noah Williams: Risk: data migration for incident postmortem action items.
Jordan Patel: I propose we split incident postmortem action items into two subtasks.
Jordan Patel: I think we split incident postmortem action items into two subtasks.
Avery Kim: Risk: scope creep for incident postmortem action items.
Priya Singh: Let’s not block on incident postmortem action items; ship a thin slice.
Samira López: Risk: scope creep for incident postmortem action items.
Noah Williams: Okay, who can take ownership?
Jordan Patel: Let’s finalize target date in Jira after this.
Noah Williams: We’ll review outcomes in the next standup.